à voir à mon bébé de la rédac balance
tout celui-ci avant la publicité dit que
j'avais beaucoup de dossiers sur casta
l'insee dans un instant mais d'abord
c'est le 50 secondes inside tpp tout ce
qui se passera et et pu pendant les
magnétos c'est magnifique c'est
exceptionnel les loups scénique aux
samouraïs et nikon d90 et arte salut à
tous et bienvenue dans sa carte green
side qui est payant comme on se suit
avec baba en mode tartine hunting cette
semaine chez north comme ça dans le paf
qui je demande moi 3
[Musique]
de cette semaine cyril et chroniqueurs
sont en mode toc qui c'est qu'a pété qui
s'inquiétaient spacek a pété il a vu
qu'ils m'ont que depuis quelques jours
nicolas pernikoff à des nouveaux délires
mais jusqu'où ira-t-il toi et tes
enfants
vous voulez savoir pourquoi benjamin
castaldi l'a plus d'oseille repoussant
d'une main a dit balsillie balle ok tu
es là décidément casse-tête un gros
pigeon même paire les cov lui prend tout
son oreille
j'ai joué à castel l'écho et le soir
hier nous méfier tous les biais qui
avait retiré
il faut jouer benjamin génial aussi et
vous voulez faire garder votre enfant ce
week end
après carla montiel et tous en rien une
soudaine la ressent et samian pas en
forme ils sont mignons et cyril hanouna
et nicolas pernikoff sont très studieux
pendant les émissions et ça se voit et +
coupes en amont thiel et le chroniqueur
préféré de cyril hanouna même été juste
laissera pas faire avec arthur bernard
montiel or là tous les jours ici
mais ce qu'on l'a et on sent pas les ont
fini ce 50 secondes inside avec une note
de poésie signé tu fais des bons voisins
et copina m'a parlé de l'avocat avant de
retrouver
elle a dit qu'elle aimerait bien voir
son barreau
[Rires]
ce
j'adore au nombre assure bernard montiel
et mvp britannique et sera la semaine
prochaine celles en ce moment vous
considérait plus comme un animateur
interviewer ou comme un entraîneur en
gagnant en galère eh bien vous avez
raison puisque depuis plusieurs jours en
soit de plus en plus fabrice di vizio on
adore les téléspectateurs au suspense à
la maison tant brillé vidéo alors on les
aime pour ses qualité d'avocat mais on
aime aussi parce qu'il vient défoncer
tout le monde il y en a qui prend un
malin plaisir à chaque fois c'est le
gangster à côté noyal
[Musique]
monsieur oui alors sur quoi vous fondez
car il va défoncer il va tout [ __ ] ta
race c'est impossible à faire bien sûr
que non c'est pas impossible à faire
c'est un poème de vol on va te défoncer
je trouve que la seule façon de ce2
ralenti en tout six dans son froc estia
il nous dit il faut pas confiné il vous
dit qu'on regarde les désastres que ça
produit
copan à ta gueule alors moi je suis bon
je crains malheureusement il est
accueilli dans son froc de nouveaux
maîtres des vidéos mais ceux ci dessus
je moi je suis comme vous je ne me
réjouis pas dans ton froc toshiba dessus
tout en attendant j'apprécie votre
démarche de mener là il n'aime pas les
teintures de gens comme vous que si ces
bons qui ne visait rien et qui
effectivement venez pérorer sur des
plateaux télé avait alors je suis un peu
d'accord avec vous c'est vrai que vous
venez pérorer sur un bateau des tournées
avec une étude qui date du 15 juillet
verra s'est dit maurice avec
d'équipement trouver une étude et acajou
compresseur suivait au nom mais taper
rohmer est de pérorer et bien dès lors
je vous pose la question savez-vous ce
quelques vip rennes c'est quoi le convie
brève
non mais c'est quoi on annonce est pas
là on est bon on n'a pas révisé bordel
on n'a pas révisé
[Rires]
descente à tourcoing vidéo elle faisait
peur de lui quoi tu viens gilles verdez
quand vous avez pas peur d'eux le
challenge est il vient avec ses faux
dossiers j'aime bien lui la seule motion
survie d'organiser un duel vous fasse sa
femme lui 500 a gagné d'avancé pour moi
[Rires]
ces boues ligne rose poudré qui veulent
une chemise de bowling qui fait seul
instant d'avoir un groupe oui quand même
s'est encore l on aime bien c'est encore
elle alors je vous le dis la marque
c'est toujours le prénom d'une jeune
fille nue et voilà comment de charrier
sur mes fringues et la game jantes ont
eu des ennuis d'aerolia rien ça fait 15
ans vous mettez le même costume de
bagnard le mec qui l'a 28 piges encore
son costume quand il avait 12 ans je
vois bien là alors eh bien j'ai calmé
les cirés jaunes tête de ma mère
si vous payez un costume pour prendre la
tension 18 18 ans ferme à terre enfin
battre cassé le bras alors il ya des
mesures de sécurité je sais pas oui mais
on est devant moi j'suis négative a pas
c'est pas pour vous j'espère que oui
tapie là
[Applaudissements]
je peux rester milan en fait j'avais pas
ta chronique on a pu alors si cette
semaine on a lancé un nouveau un nouveau
programme bush avait lancé un nouveau
programme le 6 à 7 avec art un mec avec
toast à ma langue afin de faire bloquer
sur peter sachetat je te le dis là tu es
mal et donc on se demande autour de la
table ce qu'ils ont pensé de cette
émission merci mais il est pareil sa
boule dans la vie sans problème et non
mais c'est pas donné mais de l'eau ça
pique à l'aimer de longue date avaient
jamais ma parole et dans ces conditions
sa balle est bonne ici ont sabré fait
une gaffe c'est une autre bouteille ça
va mieux mon chéri allez un peu de
fraîcheur
oui donc on parle de cette nouvelle
émission hebdomadaire animé compenser
l'écran tu te rends autour de cette
table alors j'ai une idée de séquences
simone est ce que quelqu'un a compris ce
qu'eux
donc mes six à sept avec casas compenser
les chroniqueurs on a ainsi une nouvelle
séquence irrite les appelle le tarbas
bâtards bas nous savons ce que c'est le
tama tarmac qu'est ce que c'est c'est en
gros parce que les chroniqueurs on
pensait de l'effet on commence avec
guillaume genton et jean michel mr
ont-ils été des tares bas avec benjamin
castaldi
la réponse en images j'ai vu j'ai connu
j'ai réglé mon téléviseur j'ai allumé g
c'était des problèmes de dons de ses
bras sa faute de quoi
ah ouais t'as été ils étaient deux gros
tarbes a donc oui jouer avec nous à la
maison au tarbes a pas tarder on va les
faire au cas par cas
cyril d'accord on continue avec nicolas
pernikoff à votre avis est-ce que c'est
un tarbais nicolas nicolas
il a pété un parent avec nicolas nicolas
non on regarde avec mon arme j'ai trouvé
ça incroyablement bien et c'est très
bien pour la nuit dit un autre concert
au dernier moment j'ai bien aimé ce mois
qu'il serait très bien c'était très bien
patard pas
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes très fort maintenant à une
guinée pas là mais qui a regardé
l'émission de benjamin castaldi du début
jusqu'à la fin ses petits fanny
bonvoisin tarbes en c# net
la réponse en images est super super
débits sont alors bonjour c'était bien
bon franchement c'était bien c'était
bien démerdé les sujets étaient
vachement des jets quasiment tous
regardé parce que ça de prévoir pour ce
soit il importe de trouver sa nature
même de ça c'est lui mais sous compacte
et je suis comme ça elle appuie la
formule est magnifique un sac à dos et
japon - jamin bravo mais c'est
magnifique
jouer avec toi la maison passe
maintenant à un autre duo après un agent
me et j'entends oui j'adore il à
géraldine et bernard montiel qu'on sait
que la recette on sait que bernard
montiel est un [ __ ] méthyle un [ __ ]
tarbes a foncé
c'est fini ça c'était avant c'est vers
l'avant énorme succès d'un brevet et
tina on va maintenant lui sucer oui tout
ça et il a notamment bâti vas-y tu me
suis face au réal avait cédé librement
même gilet brodé thibault bon pas bon
oui c'est aussi là en plus depuis
quelques mois quand tu pars en commun
c'est tout il est passé une série
d'accords pas tarde pas
pato non borba
saguenay les bravo en tout cas monsieur
fini ce tarbas bâtards bas avec gilbert
d'agile berbère dites moi les yeux dans
les yeux qu'avez vous pensé des missions
benjamin castaldi pour moi en ce moment
yann je dis ça sans flagornerie à deux
animateurs dans le paf ya cyril bien sûr
il ya la renaissance du phénix casal
discovery formidable toujours moi je dis
toujours les choses cyril vous le savez
une montagne de téléspectateurs gilbert
base est il un terme à bon je pense que
déjà la boe regardant les images des
versions 2
elle sera tirée de tous les angles
ça va prendre
il arrivait
[Musique]
orban gibernau alors justement autour de
la table avant que sacha continue oui
franchement est-ce que vous ne trouvez
pas que benjamin castaldi est en train
de renaître et benjamin castaldi est en
train vraiment j'ai l'impression que
c'est benjamin button
j'ai encore rajeuni plus heureux qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
c'est très bien mais si vous pensez que
non dit non non mais je trouve qu'il ya
une bonne pour le bien le connaître
ça fait plus de 25 ans qu'on se connaît
je trouve qu'il a une période où je le
trouvais triste à mourir se trouve à
nouveau heureux je le trouve d'abord
même physiquement je trouve qu'il est
fit il attendre aux îles et voilà il a
il est rayonnant et je trouve qu'en
animation du coup à un moment il se
cherchait on était un peu trop dans
maintenant le dans le copiage de vous et
là il est en train de devenir le
redevenir lui-même témoignera dans un
instant d'accord je trouve effectivement
qu'il est en paix avec lui même depuis
quelques temps et en comble depuis qu'il
est à nouveau papa je le trouve beaucoup
plus calme plus serein alors il fait
toujours 45 choses à la fois mais je
trouve qu'effectivement il devient de
plus en plus intéressant par contre qui
rajeunit alors là je ne sais pas comment
il fait mais effectivement il rajoute
donc mon à magali franchement je vous
lis aussi roger esthétique vous va
extrêmement bien mais c'est dingue et
surtout la bouche en fait
[Rires]
delphine moi je suis et je suis d'accord
avec nicolas je pense que le fait
d'avoir été papa à nouveau sa le oui les
plus épanouis et ça se sent vraiment à
l'écran ça son mariage en paix oui
exactement
je pense ça veut dire irréelles temps
déjà il en train de changer physiquement
il en pleine métamorphose avait perdu
beaucoup de poids bravo j'ai toujours
non mais c'est vrai et c'est un truc
c'est un excellent animateur il est très
très bon dans six à sept avec casta
j'adore ouais j'adore quand à dire
vraiment à trouver de nouveaux berne a
mentionné je la sucrerie se dit comme ça
ça passe et le plexi sa toune alors moi
sincèrement avant de participer à tpm
pêche pensée très sincèrement que tu
étais pas du tout sympa je pensais j'ai
pensé que c'était quelqu'un de dieu puis
j'ai fait sa connaissance je te trouve
très marrant très rayonnement
sincèrement c'est marrant ça c'est
benjamin d'une famille de gens
sympathiques son père mange ladder
j'adore lui aussi ce qui est vrai c'est
que maintenant il est redevenu et
animateur vous savez que le chroniqueur
c'est un autre métier d'être là
chroniqueur non c'est autre chose que
d'être animateur il est tout seul à
diriger
j'ai entendu
[Musique]
salez des wii donc kenzy donc sa femme
et ses deux métiers différemment
chroniqueur et animateur là il redevient
animateurs grande écoute pas vous avez
d'abord il a du talent il est sympa et
là il s'épanouit forcément il est
animateur c'est son vrai métier
allez là l'analyse ali alors d'abord est
ce qu'on peut faire une analyse
esthétique mais moi je trouve
effectivement qu de plus en plus beau
tiercé des lèvres il a refait sur les
bourses sont de plus en plus
[Rires]
et là c'est lui et moi c'est un binôme
et maintenant il est beaucoup plus
sérieux c'est vrai d'accord il est
beaucoup plus l'animateur oui il a fait
de la chirurgie esthétique
ah oui d'accord ah oui quand même ça lui
va très bien baba pharmacie rue 6 ou
voulez-vous nice quand c'est réussi six
réussies gilbert des je n'ai jamais
entendu autant de conneries c'est dit il
ya eu un naufrage de 15 ans et une peut
que remonter la pente
l'action roche la parole longue à
remonter quand même de mode bailly en
grèce même si moi je me régale un très
bon dans leur excellent dans le 6 et 7
rbds et là je l'avais dans l'édition de
mai serait que je vais mais ce qui s'est
passé un jour savoir qu'étant mais je
vais mieux je vais pas vous mentir c'est
vrai que c'est vrai qu'il a et dernière
c'était un peu compliqué voilà c'est je
n'étais pas en forme
je pense que comme vous comme beaucoup
de gens il ya eu le confinement et
alcaide qu'on compte des conséquences
sur tout le monde et j'ai dit c'est que
j'étais aimé et elle a eu la bonne année
j'étais triste frais des tris c'est vrai
c'est vrai peut-être a changé c'était
tri j'étais un peu éteint ouais mais
après ça dans la vie c'est à ce moment
qu'ils arrivent à aller les choses vont
mieux ça faisait un petit garçon qui me
qui m'a qui m'a forcé à être en forme
avec benoit je suis là je suis très en
forme ce type d'alliance en de vente et
je fais si cette heure de sport par
semaine mais vraiment je peux je prêtais
la forme castadi avant il péter mackay
c'est non mais et après c'est vrai que
après c'est toujours pareil ou fait
confiance je ne fais confiance on a un
groupe qui on a un beau projet pour le
mois d'avril début avril sous pression
pour en parler encore mais il savait
très belle soirée
grande soirée
[Rires]
sacré que plus ça va plus ça va mieux ça
va bien serait moi non mais c'est vrai
j'ai conçu dans un sens ou dans l'autre
sens quand ça va mal
généralement quand les voilà les
emmerdes arrive c'est souvent en
escadrille et quand le bonheur arrive
c'est aussi attention genia mieux ça pue
ça j'attends lola dernier magnéto toyota
oui j'allais pas repartir sans parler
des petits plats ce serait une petite
enveloppe à la lecture m'a permis de sa
gêne avec de la barre médecin vous savez
c'est comme un peu dans les mariages ont
fait de table et dessus il ya des noms
de table est un sport et moi passionnés
des médias de du paf quoi ah ouais
jamais jamais jamais donné des noms des
missions non armés table alors qu'à ma
part mais des landes ali avec des chiens
alors y avait déchiré y avait une tape
motus avec des bleus bail avec
secret-story il y avait moins il y avait
plein d'émissions way avec des émissions
page en question
il y avait il y avait six classes torre
avec s'était d'ailleurs matap c'était la
table du bar mitzvah tracy letts story
c'était vital top secret story c'est pas
ça le plus fort le plus fort c'est que
il ya ma tante qui est arrivé et pour
accéder à la salle il y avait des
escaliers d'accord et elle s'est pété la
gueule
elle s'est cassé l'épaule samu pompiers
tout ça et tout s'est calmé grosses
traces rahama bar mitzvah parce qu'elle
est tombée dans les escaliers est ce que
vous savez à quelle table elle était
prévue
ne parlons pas attention à la main
attention à la marche et non
attention à la marche ou voyez ça valait
le coup a laissé hier soir et après ça
s'est bien passé donc je peux reprendre
ma chronique
allez va bien sûr gaëtan bong à l'est et
donc je voulais terminer cette chronique
évidemment en parlant de vous parce que
j'ai l'impression que vous êtes un peu
assagi en ce moment aux appareils cette
année un peu plus sales s'agit secada
sans cela c'est dans le sol c'est
toujours le trublion du paf on va pas se
mentir mais il est un peu plus sage il
aime tout le monde en fait avant il
aller plus dans le clash plus dans le
frigo là il aime tout le monde mais
peut-être un peu trop que l'on regarde
dans l'emballement bas là c'est beaucoup
d'honneur va mieux merci nos rentes et
un avion je peux lui faire un bisou
[Musique]
ça monte ça monte pour julia et ça me
fait bien bien venir plaisir pour lui
parce que vous savez comme comme jacques
julien combes et mon ami je le dis c'est
mon ami senna pilar s'était portée de la
semaine dans 50 minutes inside et
j'embrasse mon ami achètent des
habitants mais c'est vrai que j'ai
vianney mon pote qui est à moi aussi
alors vianney pour moi et je le dis en
téléspectateurs c'est la révélation télé
de l'année merci d'être là bonsoir bon
je vous dis j'ai un gros gros coup de
coeur pour loïc voit il le sait je me
kiffe de ouf
donc c'est très contents qu'il soit là
aujourd'hui et je voudrais remercier
pierre farges avocat pénaliste toujours
un bonheur de le voir
merci bière versé aux libyens on
embrasse le comité idaho qui ont
embrassé que j'aime sort merci et merci
christine d'amour pour tout bien sûr sur
ses new skies car face à une très belle
vente en masse très fort salut mon chéri
de mercy en ph l'adorent jean-pierre et
tu sais benji tu sais que je suis fou de
ton père
lesquels amour ça rigole toujours quand
je te vois toujours comme tout ma
passion d'un branchement eau thé
je regrette le moins curieuse excuse moi
non mais j'ai envie je les adore les
cons les courriers consensus merci à
l'arrêt ça y est à la semaine prochaine
[Applaudissements]